[Music]
so
clearly you know more about money than i
do that's why i like sitting with you on
the show
because i get to ask questions and then
i take little notes and then i go out
and
change the way i'm doing things at my
house back in
april you released a youtube video based
on a kiplinger article that was
entitled 10 reasons you will never get
out of
debt yes you took umbrage to that we
heard the building shake when you read
it
right as you pounded both of these ham
fists you have on the floor
the building shook hands they are not
petite
so chris kiplinger suggests there are 10
reasons why you will never get out of
debt
i don't think that's true you don't
think that's true give us a couple of
of tools give us a couple of reasons why
that's shenanigans well here's the deal
i mean i
a i didn't like the title because it's
telling people what they can't do which
gets me riled up there you go right and
uh
you know i want people to believe in
what they can do however
uh it's a depressing title but we're
gonna do the opposite so
i don't care how much debt you have with
the right strategy commitment and effort
you can pay it off
now there were 10 reasons why people
stay in debt i'm going to share with you
five and here's the deal number one
you don't know how much you owe right
you're going to stay in debt if you
don't know how much you owe people are
scared to look at their credit report
scared to look to see exactly how much
they they have in debt
it's going to be imperative for you to
look at this and acknowledge it and
stare it in the face
number two reason you would probably
stay in debt you only pay the minimum
payment
okay sending 10 a month when you owe 2
000
you're not doing anything okay you're
not gonna make any kind of progress
credit card companies want you to pay
the minimum that's why they're a billion
dollar industry they
love for you to do this because it means
you're gonna hang around for a long time
we're not doing that we're gonna leave
them high and dry for example dr d
if you have a five thousand dollar
balance on a credit card with a fifteen
percent annual percentage rate
and you make the minimum payment of of
the two percent of the balance
how long do you think it would take you
to pay it off ten years
no try again 15 years you're sad 20
years
no 27 years 27 years
it's it and and you you to pay off it's
ridiculous
so if i have 5 000 bucks and i go
to the hardware store and i buy
a mower and a shovel and i don't know
what would add up to in a grill
you're telling me that 30 years later
you can still be paying on it
good lord hands down and the 15 in this
in this
example is generous it's 19.5 right now
but anyway i digress
another reason you probably could stay
in debt you don't have any money for
emergencies
so when life happens guess what you have
to do you got to reach back to her debt
because you don't have any money but
chris i'm in great shape and i'm young
and emergencies don't happen to me
there's no such thing as things that
happen out of the blue that i don't know
about
you know what if someone looked me in my
eye and told me emergencies doesn't
happen to them i'd avoid them like the
plague
because second is coming something is
coming okay matter of fact the
hair on my neck stood up when you said
that it made me nervous
uh oh this one and i'm gonna look at you
when i say this another reason you'll
probably stay in debt
you can't say no to your kids say
no to your kids parents take on debt for
their kids
little things like eating out and they
call these things up by the counter
sucker buys right a little candy and
things up here because little kids grab
them
and they want them yeah tell them you
know what kids love
what you your time you know what that
cost
zero dollars zero cents zero dollar zero
cents
you could take a dad and a mom and some
dirt clods
and a tennis ball and a stick and have a
great
free afternoon i just made those out you
can just have a what did you say
dirt what some dirt clods a tennis ball
a stick you are from texas and a
screwdriver and a pony you have the
the day of your life because you know
what your kids want you yeah
all of these little eating out things
and toys and clothes
that's about mom and dad you're right
dude all right final one
you got to go watch the video to get the
rest of them number five
you feel a sense of entitlement we
talked about saying no to kids but can
you say no to yourself
but christopher i work so hard i deserve
it lord listen to me my dad was mean to
me i deserve it
listen if we actually got what we
deserved
whoo don't even want to go none of that